the northern lights are just absolutely
mesmerizing and beautiful
they are kind of hard to describe
sometimes
but when it's dark at night i come alive
my name is todd salat and i'm a
full-time aurora hunter
i chased the northern lights for a
living
i wanted to photograph the auroras
and then share that with the world
[Music]
the northern lights are also known as
the aurora borealis
the sun kicks off all this electrons and
protons and those electrons come zinging
down and they release little photons of
light and they glow aurora photons
[Music]
my ticket to alaska was with geology
i scored a job up here with an oil
exploration company
and i was shooting a roars on the side i
was moonlighting as an aurora hunter
all of a sudden one day i just woke up
and said wow i want to do this
full time so
i basically resigned and that's how it
started
i like to say i have a nine to five job
which is basically nine pm to five am
and i love it
it allows me to you know connect with
the moon the stars
and the aurora of course
[Music]
that aurora comes out and you're just
you're just locked on
they dance across the sky and ripple in
patterns and turbulence
and the auroras help me you know
look away from the earth and deep into
space you just you can just look that
way forever
i don't think a day goes by where i
don't appreciate what i do
i get to basically live my dream
you